we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P
here is a caller who I think believes I
really did lose my YouTube channel I
don't even know what that would mean but
this caller seems to believe I lost my
YouTube channel
and mentions not Satan but Satan Satan
I've never heard this before listen
hey where'd You Go I mean on YouTube
I've seen that ring of fire
idiot he got tried to use your Pac-Man
stuff on YouTube what true I think I
think what the caller means is Farren
filled in for me last week not even on
there you're all gonna have a ring of
fires called the Lake of Fire
and I hope you like swimming with Satan
Satan okay
um I I did not actually get kicked off
of YouTube it was an April Fool's gag on
April 1st weeks ago
everything's fine
and I don't know what to do about Satan
but I will certainly uh look into it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves as bad I'm
going to tell you all about my trip last
week got recognized by some interesting
folks over in the UK had a confrontation
with a customs officer at JFK airport on
my way back so many stories some of
which maybe are remotely interesting to
you on today's bonus show producer Pat
will join me so much to discuss sign up
at joinpakman.com get instant access to
the bonus show and use you can use the
coupon code indicted or indicated
whichever spelling you prefer indicted
or indicated both get you a discount at
joinpakman.com